[Applause]
[Music]
the peruvian state faces difficult
challenges in the short and medium term
it needs a new way of mining in its
territory pedro castillo the current and
controversial president of peru wanted
to make his intentions clear with this
phrase during his inauguration speech a
new way of mining not only that pedro
castillo has promised a political and
economic revolution for the country for
example during this same inaugural
speech he also made it clear that from
now on the peruvian state will require
all mining and industrial projects to
pay more taxes and also to comply with a
new criterion social profitability
[Applause]
[Music]
in other words for a project to be
approved it will not only have to be
profitable and pay the agreed taxes to
the peruvian state but now it will also
have to comply with other aspects such
as boosting the surrounding economy
supporting local culture or preserving
the environment on the other hand these
are all things that they are supposed to
be doing with their activity with the
taxes that they pay and with the
regulations and standards required by
the state well all this about social
profitability is something that the new
government is going to have to explain
in detail
when pedro castillo talks about social
profitability it is easy to see that he
does not know the tax contribution of
mining nor the direct and indirect boost
to the labor force generated by mining
projects nor their level of innovation
and technology transfer carlos galvez
former president of the national society
of mining petroleum and energy the fact
is that pedro castillo a native of
kahamaka one of peru's most important
mining regions has put the industry in
his sights
pedro castillo says he will not allow
mining companies to plunder peru pedro
castillo we will nationalize mining
companies if the people require it and
remember we're talking about the most
important sector of the peruvian economy
peru is a global mining power and just
counting the projects currently underway
the total runs to tens and tens of
billions of dollars and that that has
caused us at visualpolitik to ask
ourselves a few questions what role does
mining really play in peru why has pedro
castillo put the mines under the
spotlight how is it possible that this
industry generates so much social
disapproval how can this sector
contribute to peru's future and perhaps
the most important question of all what
exactly is at stake listen up
[Music]
by the way if you want to keep up to
date with everything that is happening
in latin america don't miss latin
politics our newsletter specifically
dedicated to current events in this
region we'll leave you all the details
that you need in the description
mining in peru wanted dead or alive
peru is one of the largest mining powers
in the world for example according to
the u.s geological survey in 2019 the
country was the second largest producer
of copper silver and zinc worldwide was
also one of the largest producers of
gold lead and tin among many other
resources because if one thing is clear
it is that the country has practically
everything
many other mining countries have mainly
one mineral and this adds additional
risk when prices fluctuate peru has the
advantage of being able to smooth out
some of the price fluctuations based on
the diversified basket of metals diego
macera general manager of the peruvian
institute of economics all this explains
why mining accounts for around 10 of the
country's gdp and not only that it also
generates as we shall see between 15 and
20 of all public revenue and is
responsible for almost 60 percent of
peruvian exports to give you an idea
between 2010 and 2019 the country earned
an average of 25 billion dollars
annually in mining exports as you can
imagine this is a vital source of
foreign exchange for the peruvian
economy and that's not the end of it
[Music]
the mining sector also directly employs
some 200 000 formal workers and is
estimated to indirectly generate more
than 1.3 million additional jobs this is
due in part to the fact that jobs in the
mining sector are more productive and
are characterized by paying much higher
salaries slightly more than double those
common in the rest of the peruvian
economy
[Music]
in addition we would then have to take
into account about half a million more
people who are estimated to work in what
is known as informal mining that is
mining that is carried out illegally or
outside of state permits and regulations
and we'll talk about this later
basically mining is almost as important
to the peruvian economy as exarta making
an omelette however let's put the brakes
on because despite all this as we have
seen the new government has put this
industry squarely in the firing range so
the question that we could all ask
ourselves is why on earth would a
government go for the jugular of an
industry that is of such importance to
the country well don't think for a
moment that he does it by chance or
because he doesn't know what he's doing
his move was extremely political and
that's because mining is a terribly
unpopular industry in peru why well for
several reasons firstly because it has a
very high impact on the terrain
mining activity occupies enormous
amounts of land for example a single
operation such as yanacocha the largest
gold mine in south america occupies an
area of 6.2 mile 10 kilometers long by
3.1 mile 5 kilometers wide that's 19.2
square miles 50 kilometers squared and
of course it's not just about the land
it also requires enormous amounts of
water in areas where in many cases the
inhabitants have serious supply problems
then usually the movement of trucks and
heavy machinery also affects life crops
and pastures in rural areas due to the
large amount of dust that is raised and
in addition if things are not done
properly the risk of contamination is
very high with serious implications even
for people's health
on top of all this the biggest problem
problem number one is the feeling that
rural communities have of being robbed
that is to say that the enormous
business that the mining companies make
with the exploitations in peru does not
end up translating into a clear
improvement in the living conditions of
locals and that's without taking into
account those that experience clear
disadvantages
[Music]
for example we have the case of
cajamarca pedro castillo's native home
and the poorest region in the country
despite having a powerful mining
industry and plenty of natural resources
to exploit despite this roads and
infrastructure are deplorable and almost
half of the population exists in severe
poverty
they don't even pay taxes in a fair way
from here they take out the gold that is
sent to all parts of the world and the
communities of kajamarca continue to
live in misery juan chilon peruvian
left-wing activist and politician the
distrust of the mining industry is so
great that despite being such a poor
region the authorities have put the
brakes on multi-million dollar mining
projects in recent years this was the
case with the conquer project a huge
gold mining project with an initial
investment of almost u.s five billion
dollars
[Music]
and take note because we are talking
about a feeling that has been spreading
throughout the country particularly in
the mining regions and all this helps to
explain why there are so many social
conflicts for example according to the
ombudsman office during the first
quarter of 2021 alone 80 active mining
related conflicts were registered now
where is the truth in all this is it
true that mining companies are so
irresponsible is it true that they
hardly pay any taxes well just as in any
good story there are going to be some
murky areas regarding environmental
impacts and labor exploitation it must
be said that most of the problems are
associated with illegal mining or the
malpractice of officials who have the
duty to control compliance with
established regulations or to prosecute
illegal exploitation and remember these
are not minor issues
[Music]
to give you an idea according to
estimates by the consulting firm macro
consult almost 30 of all gold production
was carried out in illegal mines mines
which of course do not comply with
environmental occupational safety public
health protection requirements or any
basic requirements at all illegal mining
has been responsible for the
deforestation of huge amounts of forests
poisoning soil and endangering the
health of thousands of thousands of
people this is because mining uses
highly toxic reagents that if not
managed correctly can cause many
problems
and now we come to the key question are
pedro castillo and so many other
peruvian activists and politicians right
in declaring that mining multinationals
pay hardly any taxes is it true that
peru's wealth is being plundered why on
earth is it so hard to see economic
progress in mining environments listen
up
[Music]
the money that does not come
let's see is it true that large mining
companies hardly pay any taxes in peru
well to answer this question the first
thing that we have to take into account
is that in peru mining is subject to
several main taxes firstly like any
other company they have to pay income
tax that is the tax on profits but then
they also face mining royalties the
special mining tax and the special
mining levy as a result according to
calculations by the peruvian institute
of economics mining companies operating
in peru face a tax burden of at least
47.07
of their profits this is higher than the
average set by the main mining countries
in other words mining companies in peru
pay more than what is customary in
countries such as canada australia chile
or the united states among many others
between 2009 and 2019 alone mining
companies in peru paid 85 billion souls
in taxes that's roughly 25 billion
dollars given the exchange rate at the
time and take note because to this tax
burden we have to add the money that the
mining companies pay in salaries social
contributions and contracts with local
companies if we put everything into the
equation it is clear that peru earns
much much more from mining operations
than any other company that exploits
deposits in the country come on looting
looting how can you call that looting
well i don't think so but then why on
earth do communities seem to struggle to
move forward why is it that in many
cases the local population feels that
the multinationals take the resources
and they are left with nothing well this
is when we come to what is known as the
mining canon
[Music]
let me explain the sub national entities
the regions municipalities and districts
where there is mining activity received
50 of the revenues collected by the
state each year to be spent in theory on
public investment and together with the
mining cannon we also find the gas
cannon the oil cannon and the mining
royalties in other words the
sub-national entities in the areas where
natural resources are exploited receive
a lot of income every year
we are talking about more than 2 billion
a year for regions that are generally
very poor despite this social
dissatisfaction seems more than evident
municipalities that received the most
mining cannon voted for peru libra well
do you know what the problem is
because of the low level of the peruvian
political class which by the way we
already covered in a recent video which
i'll link for you in the description
they spend the money badly and that is
when they manage to spend it all
according to data from the mef between
2009 and 2019 they barely managed to
allocate a little more than 60 percent
of the available budget this means that
the main mining regions are leaving more
than 1 800 million souls per year in the
draw paid by the mining industry in
other words these sub-national entities
have billions and billions of souls
sitting in national bank accounts while
their regions lack all kinds of basic
infrastructure and that what can i say
is not so much the fault of the mines
but of a policy
there is plenty of money here
sub-national authorities do not have to
ask for more resources what they have to
work is on how to better manage those
resources the discourse that companies
contribute very little as some claim
ignores the excessive resources that
these authorities have louise miguel
castilla director of vedenza consultors
in 2020 due to the coronavirus crisis
the royalty was much lower only 4.5
million sold in spite of this
sub-national governments and
municipalities still barely allocated a
little more than 50 percent of this
amount and then you have to subtract
corruption from what they do manage to
spend earlier for example we saw the
case of kahamaka the poorest region of
peru and the birthplace of pedro
castillo
[Music]
kahanaka is a province of 1.3 million
inhabitants where almost 50 percent of
the population lives in conditions of
severe poverty where 20 of the homes do
not have electricity 26 do not have
running water and 62
are not connected to sanitation networks
well between 2009 and 2018 alone this
region received almost 1.2 billion
dollars to carry out public investment
from the mining cannon and royalties of
this amount almost half 47 was not
allocated it was not spent
in spite of all this almost 30 percent
of the public budget of all sub-national
entities in this region was financed by
the canon mineiro and royalties so
clearly it is here and in illegal mining
which obviously pays nothing where the
big problem lies and why so many
peruvians have the impression that the
mining companies pay much less than they
really do now we come to the last big
question what repercussions could
castillo have for the future of peruvian
mining listen up
australia or venezuela the latin
american alternative
the development of green energy is
driving up demand for mineral products
of all kinds such as copper which is
increasing in price this is a real
opportunity for countries like peru
for example the andean pacific and
amazonian country currently has a
portfolio of mining projects with an
estimated investments totaling almost 60
billion dollars projects that according
to estimates by the peruvian institute
of economics could translate into tax
revenues of millions and billions of
dollars over the next few years
[Music]
the problem is that many of these
projects are at a standstill and to make
matters worse the arrival of castillo
with all his threats may slow them down
even more this is exactly what is at
stake in peru
[Music]
in the past things have not been well
managed in many cases the laziness of
many companies corruption and the
incompetence of local governments have
slowed down the development of the
country but these are all things that
can be solved peru needs investment and
the mineral industry as is the case in
for example australia could be a great
driver of prosperity in any case at this
point it is your turn what impacts do
you think castillo's arrival will have
on peru's most important industry will
he make good on his threats or will he
ultimately be more pragmatic than he
appears to be leave us your answers in
the comments and if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to visualpolitik all the best
see you next time
[Music]